let's talk about how far we've come with
this coronavirus
and how much more we still have to
figure out
since the very start of the outbreak and
throughout the pandemic
there's been a lot of debate a lot of
science
and for some of us a lot of confusion
the mixed messages leaving many
frustrated
i'm sorry what what are you like how can
you
we got to get this right everybody
there's plenty we're still learning
from how we avoid getting sick to how we
deal with it when
we do and what the future looks like all
of us
need to understand that we're going to
be living with this for
some time so here's our most recent
episode on covid19
updated with expert guidance to help us
understand the pandemic
and stay safe
[Music]
science is always evolving it's just how
science works
someone does a study publishes it then
others either confirm the results or
point out the mistakes
but that all takes time when the
pandemic started
time wasn't on anyone's side
thousands of new cases every day panic
is rising as it spreads nearly all
travel stopped lockdown which extends
beyond the streets
and into the home of every citizen
for many of us there was a lot of
uncertainty back then governments had to
rely on the information available
and the main body that's been putting
that information out is the un's world
health organization
so we spoke to their lead scientists
dealing with the coronavirus
known as sars kov2 to take us through
what we knew then
and what we know now our understanding
of this virus is evolving it's changing
it's growing
we knew it was a novel coronavirus and
what our worry was
based on our experience with sars and
with mers were
super spreading events we'll get to
super spreading events later
but first let's go over how this virus
behaves
from the moment a person is infected it
can take up to 14 days for symptoms to
appear
but usually it's between five and six
days
some people can infect others just
before they get symptoms
this is known as pre-symptomatic
transmission
other people never develop symptoms but
can still spread the virus
this is called asymptomatic transmission
but it doesn't appear to be as common
it's why we have to act like everyone's
sick because a lot of the time
we just don't know who is now the who
says that on average
a person spreads the virus to two or
three other people
it's what's called the reproduction
number it can be less
that means some people don't pass the
virus to others at all
but it can also be a lot higher under
certain conditions
that's when you have a super spreading
event this virus operates in clusters
if you have people in close contact with
one another spending
long periods of time together you have
more exposure
the virus will spread what seems to be
happening is that a small number of
infected people about 10 to 20 percent
are responsible for around 80 percent of
transmission events
for example a singer in the u.s state of
washington infected
53 people at a choir practice there was
super spreading at a mega church in
seoul
at a football game in italy and it's
still happening
we're seeing outbreaks in restaurants in
nightclubs which happen indoors
you know many people want to get back to
their normal lives they want to have
their friends
over for dinner but right now those
types of activities are safer outdoors
than they are indoors and part of that
is about how these particles move around
scientists have always known that
respiratory viruses
spread through small particles it's what
we explained back in april you can catch
it from someone coughing sneezing or
even
speaking a little too close to you but
what if those droplets
linger well those particles can linger
on surfaces
and in the air if particles are larger
they tend to travel a certain distance
let's say about a meter and then fall to
the ground
scientists call these droplets but if
they're smaller
they can stay suspended in the air for
longer and potentially travel
much further scientists call these
aerosols so if she has cova 19 and she's
talking to me from across the room
there is poor ventilation in here and
neither of us is wearing a mask
the aerosols might still reach me and
that could infect me if enough of the
virus reaches my eyes
nose or mouth it all depends on the
environment
scientists talk about the three seas
close interactions
crowded areas and closed off spaces
without proper ventilation
think for example on many occasions
how far from a person smoking you can
smell cigarette smoke so this is the
same mechanism
for the virus it travels with the air
current
but no matter the environment the advice
is the same
things like washing your hands keeping a
distance of at least a meter
and wearing a mask but there are still
people who refuse to wear them
where am i bye
[Music]
now children can spread this virus but
for some reason
they don't seem to get as sick and if
children do get it
they're way less likely to die by
mid-july in the u.s
the centers for disease control said the
virus had killed more than 150
000 people but only 17 of them were
under the age of five
but a few young people who got covert 19
have also come down to the mystery
illness
they're calling it pmis i've never felt
anything left
like it uh the pain concentrated
on the center of my chest i i didn't
know what was happening to me
why some children develop this reaction
to covet 19
and other children just laugh it off is
still a complete unknown
so lots of research is still happening
particularly with vaccines
the numbers keep changing but there are
about 170 vaccines in development
close to 30 are being tested on people
russia says it's already rolling out its
vaccine
called sputnik 5 but germany's warning
against
rushing through approvals and says a
vaccine won't be ready to give to
everyone before next year
we just have to sit tight i think we
have to be prepared that the first
vaccines that come through
may not be perfect so they might reduce
severe disease
but they might not fully stop infection
or transmission now it seems frightening
what will be do if you don't have a
vaccine but it is a possibility
let's hope you in the meantime we have
treatments that doctors
say are helping like steroids which can
reduce the chances of someone dying from
covid19 by
20 but the who recommends them only for
patients who are very sick
they say they can actually be harmful if
used for mild cases
there's other stuff scientists are still
working out like why covet 19
can be so tough on some people so even
people with mild disease
that don't necessarily require
hospitalization
it's still quite a disease to go through
and we are learning
that individuals are having long-term
effects from their infection
i had the stomach problems i had the
loss of taste and smell i'm not gonna
lie it was not fun
it's now it's five and a half months
later
and i still feel pretty unwell
a lot of us are having this weird
experience called the coveted strangle
as you're waking up you feel like
someone's choking you
doctors don't know we don't have answers
so there's a lot more to figure out
but all anyone really wants to know is
when can our lives go back to normal
the who says that's already possible but
it's a new normal
we have to take the right precautions
but they say we don't need any more
country-wide lockdowns
many countries had to introduce
lockdowns because they needed time but
now we have to lift up we have to get
out of that lockdown situation
we can target our interventions at a
small geographic level where they're
actually needed
they can be time-bound so that the
entire country doesn't need to go into
these so-called lockdown measures again
so we know what we need to do to stay
safe and we know a lot more about how
this virus spreads
now you've just got to learn to live
with it
science evolves and the guidance on
covid19 gets updated all the time
so the best way to stay informed is to
access those organizations that research
this stuff
day in and day out like the who and
others who issue health advice
stay safe and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you